you know one of the biggest debates
that's going on right now during these
pandemic times or should we let these
big companies go out of business or
should we bail them out should the
government come out and cut a 10 billion
dollar check 20 billion dollar check and
help these companies not go out of
business they're too big to fail
companies similar to what happened in
2008 and some are saying no some we're
saying yes we should bail them out and
if some are saying no or saying well
wait a minute this is not capitalism
this is a form of socialism to the big
companies because you're not letting the
smaller guys who have state discipline
maybe they've stayed liquid maybe
they're trying to compete maybe they're
better for the customers maybe trying to
offer a better proposition for their
products you're not allowing them to
compete with the bigger guys let this
cycle take its place let it take its
course if somebody else has more money
that they've say this should buy him out
and these guys ought to go out of
business and their customers will go
elsewhere we should let that take place
who's right you know when you see I
lived in LA for a long time 24 years you
would always see forest fires and it was
always a concern and there's two
different kinds of forest fires there's
a kind of forest fire that kids do they
go out in the forest they're playing
around and they you know messing around
with a match or cigarette or they're
doing something fired that's man-made
fire but there's a natural forest fire
and if you talk to people who study
nature they will tell you natural forest
fire is needed now why is natural forest
fire needed why would anybody want to
have a natural forest fire here's why
because if you ever go in a forest
that's filled with these massive trees
and you're walking you don't get a lot
of sunlight it's dark the trees are
covering everything Sun is a form of
nutrient not everything else out here is
getting the Sun the trees all the way at
the top are getting the Sun not the ones
below what do you mean by this Pat well
sometimes you need to have forest fire
why if you look at before-and-after
pictures of natural forest fires you
will notice how immediately within days
boom beautiful green all the way in the
bottom everywhere what is going on over
here those are the small business owners
or finally getting the Sun while the
entire time these too-big-to-fail
companies have been getting all the Sun
now it allows the next tree to come out
all those deep roots that are sucking
all the nutrients all of them to
themselves these other small trees
couldn't compete now the small trees can
compete with the bigger trees this is a
cyclical cycle this happens regularly
this is why you can't see here about
stats of 60 percent of Fortune 500
companies from 1970 are not around
anymore
this happens over and over and over
again because somebody may have a better
proposition today so where am I going
with this
stats small business owners in America
small business owner or somebody that
employs Dustin 500 people in their
company small business owners in America
employ 59 million people in America
nearly forty seven percent of all jobs
in America are provided by small
business owners and some tells me times
like this maybe we are going through the
process where some of these businesses
need to go out of business and make some
room for the new entrepreneur the small
business owners to come up and get
access to that Sun because maybe they
have a better proposition to the
customer that's better than the bigger
guys who for years been getting bailed
out by governments that give them money
saying hey don't worry about I know your
lobbyists behind closed doors you're
helping out my election let's make sure
we build these guys out let's make sure
we build these guys out maybe it's time
we let these guys go out of business so
the next generation of entrepreneurs the
next generation of small business owners
starts getting an opportunity to have a
better product better service better
propositions for the customers so the
next time you hear about this whole
thing of too big to fail let's bail them
out maybe it's okay for some of these
guys to go out of business what do you
think about it
you